I just got my driver's license back
though he said I think it did say I'm
fella he said I'm a felon but it was
like it was a DUI hmm and I went do you
have a driver's license yeah yeah I just
got it back like a year ago and I
thought for him to have lost his license
and be a felon he he had to have lost a
multiple time before it becomes like a
felony yeah so at that time I mean I'm
pretty sure that's how it works so I
just remember thinking you're a felon
I'm a DUI for some reason or even if it
wasn't from the DUI I'm assuming it was
I'm thinking what if he loses a license
again I could be driving around with the
guys I could have a car two cars an
apartment credit card everything in a
guy's name cuz see what I would do is I
would pair them with social security
numbers that were recently issued I
would go straight in a social security
number and get what a social security
card issued to Michael Eckert and I'd
get a whole new credit profile based on
him new address mm-hmm
so new everything lots of people had the
name Michael Eckert I changed the middle
name slightly right boom credit profile
seven hundred credit scores so buy a
bunch of buy a car house whatever my
point is is that I'm driving around what
if I get pulled over this guy's got a
DUI I go to jail I get fingerprinted I'm
done right so and Becky and I we talked
about that multiple times what if you
get what if you grabbed and I was like
look worst-case scenarios at this time I
don't know if this is how it works now
but this was 50 over 15 years ago I was
like worst case scenario is if I get
grabbed and they bring me downtown and
they fingerprint me they won't run the
prints right away they only run them
right away through APHIS if your
identities in question keep in mind my
identity won't be in question because
I'm a real driver's license so if it's
not in question they're gonna
fingerprint me you can get me I'll get
it'll be something stupid that I get
arrested for so you can easily get me
out within 24 hours you get me out
before they run my prints and we're gone
and she was like okay okay okay because
a lot of these small towns that they
don't run your prints right only they do
them in batches or they don't you know
they don't wasn't back then there was no
it wasn't the digital scanner there have
something yet so even if when they did
have them they don't necessarily run
them they get charged for running them
and your identities not in question so
we talked about that anyway my point is
I started stealing the identities of
real people but one day we're sitting at
a red light and she I said what we need
is an identity of people someone who
does it isn't really using their
identity and she's like what I said I
don't know she's like mental patients
something what I was like she's people
got people that died did I said no
because when you die it gets registered
so that they can get the death benefit
of $250 and so Social Security knows
you're dead so it shows up on your
credit profile so I can't use though
it's no good impermanent IDs and I went
she's like well I cou and I went and
there was a guy stayed in there holding
a home we you know Hungary will work for
food so I don't go like that guy yeah
that's just the bomb I was a yes so we
pull over I go up to the guy go hey man
what's up it's like what's up I said can
I ask you some questions real quick I'll
give you 20 bucks right now five minutes
yeah what's up and I started asking him
questions do you have a felony do you
have a driver's license how'd you lose
your license
was it a DUI was it you know and it
wasn't he didn't have a DUI he just
expired he doesn't have a car how would
I get a DUI mmm-hmm you know I've been
arrested multiple times I don't have a
felony though I have a bunch of
misdemeanors mm-hmm so as you start so I
came up with a statistical survey form
where I went around and I would question
homeless people I was trying to get
their information to try and determine
where we were gonna where the Salvation
Army was going to open their next
homeless facility you got 20 bucks and
say take a survey for the Salvation Army
we're trying to determine where we're
gonna know where we're going to open our
next homeless facility those were your
telling yeah and that give them 20 bucks
and I take their information they have
no clue and then I turn around I order
their birth certificate or their social
security card i order their their high
school transcripts
i order everything i then turn around i
go into a state where they don't have a
license i go into DMV hey just moved the
state lost my license here's my proof i
would register to vote in their name get
the card within a couple of days I just
registered my voters registration card
here's my birth certificate
here's my Sosh and here's my high school
transcript and I've court obviously I'm
a resident of the state sometimes I
would say have a sometimes I'd have a
lease for my apartment in the guys name
and they would go
great stand over there take a picture
bam bam bam you got a driver's license
they just print you out the driver's
license I then turn around I go straight
to to straight to the passport office
what not straight a couple days later
yeah go straight there here's my birth
certificate here's my driver's license
and they take all the information down
you pay like a fifty five dollar fee
they mail it in two weeks later you get
a passport so I mean so what happened
was once we moved from Atlanta we went
to we're going everywhere we're going to
you know we're going to Las Vegas we're
going to we go to Jamaica we're going to
where else and we're just traveling all
over the place yeah so so I remember we
went to Las Vegas and we this is what
time well how much time do we have to
guess we got a good story man this is a
good story we got plenty of time you're
gonna love this this is this is and it's
horrible and I feel bad I'd like to say
I feel bad about this okay so we go to
Las Vegas so Becky can see her son no
and we give we hand over some money and
you know she you know she's handing off
money to family and making everybody
happy and she's wor buying presents and
doing all the things that is gonna make
her feel good
so while we're there I said look let's
get let's just do some surveys yeah she
goes oh my god so we drive to an area
and there were so many homeless people I
was I was nervous about getting it's the
first place I thought of with homeless
people only that'd be perfect Las Vegas
why and I didn't want to pull out I
don't want to pull out a lot of money so
I was like man there's just too many of
them
oh yeah so she goes okay so we go to
another place imparted she well she went
she was okay another place she was well
how about these guys a couple guys
sitting on a park bench and they were
pretty clean-cut they were so clean-cut
I thought they may not be homeless
so it got out one of the guys gets up he
goes yeah what's going on I said hey
would you mind taking a survey real
quick and this happened all the time I
say and they go no I'm not interested I
paid pays $20 cash right now you're in
between those cash right now
right takes three minutes 17 questions
yeah man what's going on
I started asking the questions you know
his name Gary Sullivan date of birth so
secure number blah blah blah blah we're
going out and thing I asked ever been
arrested no like hesitation and give you
their social no really no it's a few
guys that did hesitate I would always go
cool I have to have it and I'd say well
okay I look at him I go okay well what
would I do with it and they go well you
can steal my identity I go do you have
good credit right they go no I got shoot
credit okay well then what good would it
be yeah there you go do you have a bank
account no okay I don't if you don't
want the $20 it's no big deal I got
somebody but I remember now I want to
see the Social Security card because I
don't think you're gonna give me a bad
fake number it's not gonna see it yeah
so anyway Gary Sullivan gives me its
information as we're going down the list
and I start there's random questions I
would ask you ever had a passport you
ever had how many states have you had a
driver's license in which stays that
sort of thing ones last time you were
gainfully employed that you know all
right do you have a felony and the guy
goes he is no I'm telling you I've got a
misdemeanors I don't want mister me yeah
he was yeah for prostitution okay I went
okay you mean solicitation because you
know my mind guys get charged with right
solicitation in a losses right didn't
even occur to me and I went you mean so
let's say she is no prostitution he was
I offered to blow a undercover cop for
the 20 bucks and I went really he was
yeah I've been arrested a few times
where I went oh okay I said Wow I okay
and he goes yeah he said well you know
20 bucks well [ __ ]
so he gave him a survey for time yeah I
remember I said he said that's what I
thought you were here for and that's
what would they're hanging out there for
and I went he goes this is basically an
area where sex traffickers hang out
though she Becky knew that she's sitting
in the car laughing I might he said to
unbelievable I take his information and
I leave get in the car she's telling me
talking about my boy
friend like what your boyfriend's that
it is so we leave we go back to
Charlotte we set up we're all happy I
figure okay well we need some more money
I gotta get a couple I had at least a
million dollars on the next one and we
do so I go to Columbia South Carolina I
buy a couple houses and one of the
houses I buy is a house for 200 it's
like two hundred thirty thousand so
basically I just got a realtor and we
drove around houses and I just put
contracts on owner financing I need your
owner financed I need your owner finance
it and they and you put five houses five
contracts on five houses at least one or
two of them come back and they want to
talk about it so one of the Realtors
comes back to says my clients are he's a
he's a doctor and they're moving to
Atlanta and they're interested in doing
the owner financing and I said okay cool
so I said okay so I'll give you guys 10
percent down on a two hundred and I
think was 225 225 thousand our house so
I'll give you give you 25 grand down so
and you own or finance two hundred
thousand dollars and they had a mortgage
on the house for two hundred thousand so
it's called a wraparound mortgage okay
so they're gonna give me a mortgage that
wraps around their mortgage so I pay
them they pay the mortgage company on it
so we go to the closing we have a
closing and I think Bridgette Brown is
on the American greed she I think she's
on the American greed pretty sure she is
I remember yeah I remember there was
three girls on there yeah yeah well this
was a dr. Brown's wife okay and so we go
to the closing okay we go to the closing
and we just have it's just a quick
closing I mean later on when I whoa okay
America greed she says that she talked
about how she'd had her identity stolen
before and she says that my eyes got
real wide and the lady was a kid yes
absolutely so a sick kid right yes yeah
so we go to the closing you know I do
remember her saying that I don't
remember my eyes getting wide but I
remember thinking okay
you know I'm just in and out great we're
not hanging out we're not making friends
I'm not asking any any personal
questions a she mentions that we sign I
leave I now own the house in the name of
Gary Sullivan's name so I then turn
around and I go and I I go downtown a
week or two later and I satisfy the loan
on the house in their name the one they
had and I satisfy the loan that they had
in the name of like Federal Credit Union
or something like that federal it was
like federal savings credit union or
something mink and that's when I started
signing like the the mortgage at the
satisfactions with like cartoon
characters you know like I signed it
with yeah name C Montgomery burns which
once again I thought that was extremely
cute yeah did not play well in front of
the judge a couple years later he no
sense of humor about yeah leave some
sort of like paper mache - new in
somebody's house actually not true I did
leave it and he the guy said that I left
the paper mache statue in the middle of
the living room like screaming right
taunting him right but I have a degree
in fine arts yeah fraud is not a
full-time job we're jogging
we're working out we're doing rock
climbing we're going on vacations we're
still bored yeah and one of the things I
did was I made like a paper mache guy
and I was I was working on it but by the
time we started getting the money out I
didn't finish it have time to finish it
and I couldn't fit it in the back of the
vehicle we were driving so I left it in
the garage when he shows up at closing
or at the that was pretty creepy to me
like on the show I made it sound less
you were like well yeah what's funny is
that when it it ended up at at
sentencing and on the shows it's that I
left it in the middle of the he says
when I walked in I left in the middle of
the living room within the entire house
was trashed
we had a bed upstairs in the master
bedroom we had no furniture the house
wasn't trashed we'd had the carpets
actually steam clean before we left
yeah so there was nothing to trash so it
was like you know it's like look I'm
already in a bad spot here can you can
you please not say that you know I know
you're tweaking it a little bit to make
it worse but it's already bad yes you
know so they they it's always the the
tweak of the he left it here he was
taunting me you know it was in the
garage
along with the backseat of the vehicle
we were driving because we had so much
crap we could I could with it
pull out the backseat anyway but
whatever like I said it's the same thing
it's like saying you're a murderer you
killed 13 people and you not sure I
killed 11
[Laughter]